Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Warum?
Was ist das? Wo hast du das her? Was soll das hier?
Aus dem bösen Internet. Steckt meiner 5 Sterne Liste drin und Chiptunes sind toll.
Ist Creative Commons Musik natürlich. Ich kann euch einfach runterladen. Ihr müsst einfach nur mal den Namen googeln. Ihr seid nämlich hier im Chaos Radio und da geht es heute um Bitcoins. Wir haben heute schon darüber gesprochen, was das ist und wie man das macht. Vor allem ist es eine virtuelle Währung, das heißt nicht, dass es die nicht gibt, aber das heißt, dass die vor allem im Netz existiert. Wir verwenden den Begriff mal dafür. Und die wird berechnet, dadurch, dass viele Leute sagen, okay, wir beobachten alle Transaktionen, die stattfinden. Und wenn du dem anderen ein Bitcoin gibst, dann schreiben das alle auf und dann ist das sozusagen, dadurch wird das real. Und das wird auch irgendwie berechnet und dadurch können Leute darum wieder Geld verdienen. Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich sagen muss, jetzt ist der Punkt gekommen, wo ich es nicht noch mal ganz von vorne erklären kann, ohne die ganze Sendung noch mal anzufangen. Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt gerade einsteigt und euch das zu bunt wird, dann hört den Podcast von diesem Blumenohren. Den gibt es ungefähr so eine Stunde nach der Sendung auf fritz.de, wenn die Seite wieder funktioniert und dann gibt es das da. Dann könnt ihr das doch mal ganz von vorne anfangen. Wir waren jetzt dingeblieben beim Mining bzw. das haben wir abgeschlossen. Wir hatten vorhin kurz darüber gesprochen, dass es, also wir hatten den Unterschied zwischen virtueller und realer Währung gemacht und Niels, der Volkswirt, der heute hier ist, mit Andreas Bogk vom Chaos Computer Club, hat ja gesagt, ja, also wenn man damit Geld beim Bäcker, also wenn man mit dem virtuellen Geld beim Bäcker bezahlen kann, dann wird es realer. Er hat jetzt schon präzisiert, wenn man bei jedem Bäcker damit bezahlen kann. Und das muss er nämlich tun, denn es gibt in Berlin angeblich schon einen Laden, bei dem man mit Bitcoins, also der virtuellen Währung, tatsächlich bezahlen kann. Und angeblich ist jetzt aus diesem Laden jemand hier am Telefon. Hallo Jörg.
Jo, hallo, schönen guten Abend, Markus.
Guten Abend. Du hast, also was hast du?
Was habe ich? Worüber spricht jetzt der Room 77 in Berlin-Kreuzberg? Ich würde es mal auf Berlinerisch Burger-Kneipe nennen. Ein Burger-Restaurant mit Bar und wir akzeptieren Bitcoins seit ein paar Wochen und ich habe jetzt gerade hier angerufen, weil ein Freund von mir eine Nachricht geschickt hat, ruft doch mal da an, da geht es um das Thema.
Ok, dann erste Frage. Wie bist du dazu gekommen, dass du gedacht hast, ok, Bitcoins will ich hier auch für meine Burger akzeptieren?
Weil ich von Bitcoin als Zahlungsmittel sehr, sehr überzeugt bin, ganz einfach eine große Zukunft einräume, was natürlich noch viele, viele Hürden zu überwinden hat und eine dieser Hürden ist die Anwendbarkeit in einem Einzelhandel, in einem Supermarkt oder in einem Restaurant. Und da muss ja irgendjemand mal anfangen. Genau, außerdem finde ich das Thema sehr faszinierend. Also das ist ein Zahlungsvorgang, der Spaß macht. Anders als einer mit einer Kreditkarte, der im Übrigen genauso kompliziert ist und genauso lang dauert eigentlich fast. Ja, das waren so die Gründe, warum wir dachten, wir nehmen mal gern Bitcoins an. Außerdem erspart es unangenehme Gebühren und von der Sicherheit von Kreditkartensystemen muss ich jetzt, glaube ich, als Gastronom auf dem Chaosradio nicht anfangen zu referieren, aber von der Sicherheit von Bitcoin bin ich doch relativ überzeugt.
Aber darf ich trotzdem mal fragen, du unterstützt das System schon auch aus dem ideellen Gedanken, das heißt du würdest im Zweifel auch in Kauf nehmen, dass es möglicherweise mal einen Verlust gibt, aber du wolltest einfach mal diese Idee unterstützen?
Ja, Verlustsrisiko hält sich in Grenzen, weil ich kann ja den Bitcoin mehr oder weniger tagesaktuell, wenn ich will, stundenaktuell auch wieder in Dollars oder Euros eintraden, auf der einen Seite. Und auf der anderen Seite sind die Umsätze in Bitcoin, die wir machen, noch so gering, aber tatsächlich auch allein daher, von daher, dass das Risiko in Grenzen hält.
Aber kommen wir mal zum ganz praktischen Ansatz. Wie berechnest du den Preis eines Burgers? Also kostet er bei dir eine feste Bitcoin-Mengen oder guckst du in dem Moment, wo ich den Burger kaufe, nach wie viel der Bitcoin gerade in Euro wert ist und rechnest das dann in dem Moment um?
Nö, wir haben im Moment einen von mir willkürlich festgelegten Tauschwert, der gerade bei 15, 50 Euro pro Bitcoin liegt. Das ist ja günstig für jemanden, der seine Zeche in Bitcoin bezahlen will und das tun wir ja, weil eine gewisse ideelle Motivation dahintersteckt, das Ganze zu unterstützen, zu fördern, selber damit experimentieren zu wollen und wie gesagt, die Umsätze sich so in Grenzen halten, dass ich sagen kann, dafür nehme ich das auf den Ring, das muss ich jetzt im Moment in Kauf.
Was kostet denn gerade ein Burger da?
In Euros oder in Bitcoins? Es ist ganz ehrlich so, dass ich die Preise in Euro in den Kopf hab und eine Rechnung am Ende in Bitcoin umrechne, naja so ist das, also es ist einfach so, dass...
Okay, also du sagst einfach so 15, 50 ist Bitcoin wert und dann rechnest du aus irgendwie blablabla, das kostet halt jetzt 13, 20 Euro und dann ist das irgendwie 0, blablabla Bitcoins.
Genau.
Dann, was wir uns gefragt haben, als wir zum ersten Mal gehört haben, ist wie machst du das denn eigentlich, weil so eine Bitcoin Transaktion ist ja nicht instantan, sondern bevor die sozusagen real oder echt wird, muss die ja von anderen Teilnehmern im Netz bestätigt werden. Wie läuft der Bezahlvorgang bei euch ab?
Ich würde mal so sagen, ich warte auf gar keinen Fall, bis ich die sieben Bestätigungen aus dem Netz habe, bevor ich den Gast gehen lasse. Mir ist bewusst, was für ein unheimlich großer Aufwand das wäre, mich jetzt zu täuschen wegen 0, 8 oder 2, 8 Bitcoins und was man da für eine Umfassungsinfrastruktur aufbauen müsste. Hat auch noch keiner gesehen, dass so etwas passiert ist. Ich sage eigentlich, wenn ich die Bitcoinzahlen in meinem Client sehe oder sie in der Blockchain finden kann, auch noch unter den unbestätigten Transaktionen, dann ist der Zahlvorgang für mich erledigt. Es ist auch immer angekommen. Es war noch nie so, dass das dann irgendwie nach fünf Bestätigungen nicht real geworden wäre.
Wie ist es denn, welche Art und Weise passiert das? Bringen dann Leute ihre Laptops mit?
Es gibt zwei Devices, die da funktionieren. Du bringst ein Laptop mit, auf dem du einen Bitcoin Client laufen hast oder ein mobiles Endgerät mit einem Client. Da gibt es im Moment meines Wissens nur unter Android einen Client, mit dem man Point-of-Sale oder Face-to-Face bezahlen kann, wenn man einen Mt. Gox Account hat. Also das sind die ersten beiden Lösungen im Moment. Aber ich weiß, es brodelt überall und Leute trauben auf dem Boden an Clients.
Das heißt, man kommt da hin und irgendwie hängt eure Adresse aus? Das heißt, man kommt zu euch in den Laden und eure Bitcoin-Adresse hängt da aus? Oder organisierst du die für jeden bezahlvergangenen neu oder wie läuft das?
Was auf den Laden läuft, das läuft alles auf eine Adresse und da hängt ein Zettel an der Wand, da kann man so einen QR-Code abfotografieren, so ein Barcode. Viele Leute haben da Applikationen auf ihren Handys, die das direkt in die Zahladresse ummünzen. Da steht die Bitcoin-Adresse, falls jemand abtippen will, hat auch schon mal jemand gemacht. Und es steht eine sehr kurze Web-Adresse von dem Address Shortener. Die kann man kurz, wenn man ein mobiles Endgerät hat, einfach kurz in Web-Browser tippen und dann die Zahladresse daraus kopieren. Das sind die drei Möglichkeiten, die wir bislang gefunden haben, die am besten funktionieren.
Also, wenn ihr irgendwie schon Bitcoins am Start habt und die mal in Burger investieren wollt, könnt ihr, wie heißt der Laden?
Das ist der Room 77 in Kreuzberg, auf dem Gräfelkitz, Gräfestraße 77.
Könnt ihr mal gucken gehen. Da kann man schon mit Bitcoins betahlen.
Jetzt hab ich Hunger auf Burger.
So, tja Niels, siehst du mal, bald ist es ja alles Geld. Ein Burger kann man damit schon mit zahlen. Sehr schön. So, jetzt haben wir gleich noch einen weiteren Anruf, nämlich den Paul. Der hat eine ganz klassische Frage, soll man Bitcoins jetzt oder später verkaufen?
Genau.
Wie viele Bitcoins hast du denn?
Jetzt auf dem Konto oder insgesamt gemeint?
Insgesamt. Du?
Insgesamt hab ich seit sechs Wochen 75 Bitcoins gemeint. Wo hast du die her? Ja, ich hab mir einen Rechner gekauft. Also erstmal hab ich meinen benutzt, mit meiner ganz alten Grafikkarte, da hab ich halt vor sechs Wochen ziemlich wenig Profit rausgeschlagen, weil der Bitcoin Kurs noch sehr weit unten war, irgendwie bei 5 US Dollar pro Bitcoin. Und dann hat mich ein Gruppe hat auf die Idee gebracht, ein paar Grafikkarten einzukaufen, dann hab ich mir halt erst eine gekauft, dann eine zweite, dann vor drei Wochen nochmal drei Stück. Nein. Also für den Außenstehenden klingt ja schon ein bisschen verrückt, aber es hat sich jetzt schon fast rentiert. Also das heißt, in ein bis zwei Wochen habe ich dann einen Computer mit sechs Grafikkarten und einen Super-Mainboard for free.
Ja, aber nur, wenn du zum richtigen Zeitpunkt deine Bitcoins in sozusagen anderes Geld umwandelt. Darauf besitzt du jetzt auch deine Frage, wann ist ein guter Zeitpunkt zu verkaufen?
Genau.
Warum machst du es nicht einfach jetzt? Du hast jetzt 75, der Kurs steht bei 18 Dollar, das ist doch schon irgendwie ordentlich Geld.
Ja, genau. Ich habe halt diese 32 Bitcoins. Ich habe mir irgendwie gedacht, 10 behalte ich auf jeden Fall, immer. Das heißt, ich weiß nicht ob diese...
Warum nicht 23?
Das Ding ist halt, in den letzten Wochen war der Wert von 5 US-Dollar auf 8, auf 9, dann auf 15, auf 20 und dann bis 30, 6 US-Dollar. Also das sind so 20 Euro Profit-Kollegen gestiegen und das ist halt das Ding, das ist halt sehr schwankend, in der letzten Woche ist er so immer so auf 17, 18 geblieben und deswegen wollte ich halt fragen, ob man verkaufen sollte oder nicht oder was eure Meinung dazu ist.
Also ich habe dazu keine Meinung. Was sagt Andreas?
Disclaimer, please always do your own due diligence and consult your financial advisor. We own some Bitcoins. Never invest unless you can afford to lose your entire investment. Nachdem der Disclaimer durch ist, ja, es ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen. Tendenziell ist mein Bauchgefühl, dass der Wert erstmal eine Weile stabil bleibt. Also es sieht gerade so aus, als würde der Kurs ganz, ganz langsam fallen, aber es gibt momentan viele Leute, die eher ein Interesse daran haben, dass Bitcoin eine stabile Währung bleibt, als dass sie kurzfristig Gewinne realisieren wollen. Auf der anderen Seite kann es dir passieren, dass morgen irgendwie einer von den frühen Mainern durchdreht und mal anfängt 50.000 Bitcoins auf den Markt zu kloppen und dann wird der Kurs fallen. Es kann sein, dass irgendein technisches Problem an, das noch keiner gedacht hat, auftaucht und das Geld von heute auf morgen gar nichts mehr wert ist, das nicht auszuschließen. Es kann genauso sein, dass es irgendwie gut weiterläuft, die Nachfrage steigt und steigt und steigt und steigt und deine Bitcoins irgendwann 100 Euro wert sind. Also wahrscheinlich ist die beste Strategie in dem Fall das, was du schon tust, einen Teil zu behalten und einen Teil zu verkaufen.
Also jetzt hab ich doch eine Meinung. Ich würde jetzt nämlich so machen, ich würde so lange Bitcoins verkaufen, bis ich die Hardware Investition wieder drin hab und den Rest behalten.
Ja, das war auch meine erste Überlegung.
Und jetzt fragen wir noch den Volkswirten. Niels, was sagst du? Wie wäre dein Plan?
Also mein Plan wäre wohl auch genau das zu machen, was du machst, Markus. Ich bin jetzt auch kein Börsenspezialist oder sowas. Also es kann ja halt immer passieren, dass entweder einer der Early Adopters durchdreht oder dass ein Bug im System gefunden wird, was ja passieren kann, wodurch auf einmal der Bitcoin Preis fällt. Genauso kann es sein, dass es irgendwie in den Massenmedien auf einmal auftaucht. Also der Preis ist wohl gestiegen auf 30 Dollar, nachdem es in Fox News in den USA kam und auf ein Gadget und auf einmal ein Run auf die Bitcoins los war. Wenn was ähnliches passiert, kann der Preis natürlich wieder nach oben schießen. Aktuell scheint er ja relativ stabil zu sein. Ich würde auch mal denken, dass der erstmal stabil bleibt. Von daher würde ich halt immer gucken, dass ich schon ausgebe und jetzt nicht anfange zu sparen und zu sparen und zu hoffen, dass der irgendwann mal richtig steigt. Sondern würde halt gucken, dass ich erstmal die Hardware refinanziert kriege und meinen Strom refinanziert bekomme, den ich durch die Hardware verliere. Und dann kann ich immer noch sparen und mir überlegen, ob ich nicht gegebenenfalls auch Dinge in Bitcoin kaufe, anstatt in der Währung, wenn es gegebenenfalls günstiger ist, wie einen Burger oder Socken oder Server im Netz, wenn man sie braucht.
Und im schlimmsten Fall kann man dann immer noch Counter-Strike auf 12 Monitoren gleichzeitig zocken.
Genau, darf ich noch andere Fragen? Genau, weil ich habe ja schon gesagt, ich habe jetzt insgesamt sechs Grafikkarten. Eine brauche ich dann in längerer Zukunft selber für mich, für meinen Rechner. Und die fünf anderen brauche ich ja eigentlich nicht. Und weil ja auch schon angesprochen wurde, dass die jetzt halt bei Ebay so wunderbar weggehen, diese Grafikkarten, sollte man jetzt eigentlich schon aussteigen. Weil jetzt mache ich halt nur noch sechs Euro pro Tag. Quasi schon abzüglich der Stromkosten. Und ja, sollte man jetzt kurzerhand aussteigen, die Grafikkarten noch für gutes Geld verkaufen. Oder ja, also das ist halt, da bin ich so gespeitender Meinung.
Das ist nicht der blödeste Plan. Also die Difficulty ist ganz schön hochgegangen. So vor zwei Wochen kam da noch ein Bitcoin pro Tag und Grafikkarte raus. Und mittlerweile ist es ein Viertel am Tag. Und in noch mal ein paar Tagen wird es ein Achtel sein. Ich denke, in zwei oder drei Wochen ist einfach der Punkt erreicht, wo es den Strom nicht mehr wert ist. Der Plan, jetzt die Hälfte einer Grafikkarte zu verkaufen, ist eigentlich gar nicht so blöde.
Genau, und das verstehe ich auch mit der Difficulty nicht. Weil eigentlich nach meiner Einschätzung müsste die ja immer quasi pro Block ansteigen, ein bisschen und schwanken. Aber das sieht ja so aus, dass die echt immer irgendwie alle, ich weiß jetzt nicht den Zeitabstand, aber immer sprunghaft ansteigt. Und das finde ich ein bisschen komisch, weil es wird ja immer nur eine Anzahl von Bitcoins am Tag ausgeschüttet. Und vor einer Woche oder zwei Wochen hatte ich noch zwei Bitcoins am Tag gemacht und dann von einem Tag auf den anderen nur einen Bitcoin. Und diese Differenz muss ja irgendwo bleiben. Das ist ja nicht so, dass irgendein Riesen-Mining-Pool angefangen hat und die anderen sich abgreift.
Das Problem ist, dass du sozusagen, wenn du von Block zu Block die Schwierigkeit erhöhst, hast du ein Problem zu berechnen, wie hoch die Schwierigkeit denn jetzt sein muss. Also die Idee ist ja sozusagen, dass man im Schnitt alle zehn Minuten einen neuen Block haben will. Das kann man natürlich aber nicht vorschreiben, weil ob man jetzt einen Hasch findet oder nicht, hängt ja auch ein bisschen vom Glück ab. Deswegen muss man über einen längeren Zeitraum messen, wie die Leistung des Netzes gerade ist. Das heißt, man muss über einen längeren Zeitraum messen, wie viel Blocks pro Sekunde, pro Minute gefunden werden. Und dann kann man ausrechnen, auf welchen Wert man die Difficulty jetzt setzen muss. Das heißt, man darf es nicht so oft machen. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu selten. Da würde ich zustimmen. Also einmal am Tag anpassen wäre, glaube ich, angemessen. Aber die Systemdesigner haben sich halt für alle 2000 Blocks, glaube ich, irgendwie so was entschieden.
2016 war im Chat gerade die Rede von...
2016.
Also ich hatte von 7200 Bitcoins am Tag gehört. Wird nur eine Bitcoin-Menge am Tag ausgeschüttet oder mehr? Und weniger? Also schwankt das?
Das sind momentan 50 pro Block. Und wie viele Blocks gefunden werden am Tag, das schwankt.
Also okay, gut.
Das ist abhängig vom Glück und abhängig von der Anzahl Leute, die drin sind.
Ich dachte, das wäre eine feste Blockzahl. Und dann hätte es keinen Sinn gemacht, wenn die Difficulty nicht angepasst wird.
Na man sagt, dass im Schnitt alle 10 Minuten ein Block gefunden wird.
Ja, dann bin ich eigentlich so weit durch.
Sehr schön. Paul, dann viel Spaß. Wenn du gar nicht mehr weißt, wohin mit deinen Bitcoins kannst du Burger essen gehen.
Bis dann.
Tschüss. So, Burger hatten wir schon irgendwie. Du hast gerade gesagt Socken. Was kann man denn eigentlich alles für Bitcoins kaufen?
Hauptsächlich Netzdienstleistungen. Das ist das Wichtigste, was es gibt. Serverplatz, Leute, die einem Webseiten machen, VPN-Verbindungen, solche Sachen gibt es viel. Die Socken hatte ich erwähnt, weil der Typ, der neben einem der Hauptprogrammierer der Software wohnt, der macht Alpaka-Socken. Das muss ganz tolle Wolle sein und ganz tolle Socken. Auf jeden Fall hat er den irgendwann relativ früh überzeugt, auch irgendwie auch seine Socken für Bitcoins zu verkaufen. Das ist also sozusagen das kanonische Beispiel für, man kann auch, es ist richtiges Geld, weil man kann richtige Sachen damit kaufen. Na was denn? Na Socken.
Socken und Burger. Okay, das ist im Großen und Ganzen schon das, was es war.
Na ja, es gibt dann noch die Untergrundgeschäfte, also der vor vier Wochen hat eine Webseite namens Silk Road große Schlagzeilen gemacht. Das ist so eine Art Ebay für Drogen. Da kann man also tatsächlich für Bitcoin Drogen kaufen.
Funktioniert das?
Äh, gewöhnlich gut unterrichtete Kreise behaupten ja.
Wo wir gleich zu einem nächsten spannenden Ding kommen, der Anonymität. Das ist ja eine Hoffnung, die damit verbunden wird eigentlich. Die grundlegende Idee, die hinter dem System steht, war ja zu sagen, wir wollen sowas Ähnliches wie Bargeld. Und die Eigenschaft von Bargeld ist ja tatsächlich, es ist anonym, weil diese Scheine sind zwar irgendwie einzeln und durchgehend nummeriert, aber das verfolgt ja keiner, wo die so lang wandern. Zumindest über einen großen Teil nicht. Jetzt haben wir hier aber ein System, was darauf basiert, dass sich alle Leute zu jeder Zeit ganz genau aufschreiben, wer welchen Bitcoin wohin schiebt. Das heißt, das ist ja eigentlich die totale Überwachung. Hat mit Anonymität überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Ja, das ist richtig. Anonymität war als Designkriterium offensichtlich nicht so wichtig, wie die Tatsache, dass es keine zentrale Instanz gibt. Ich hatte von erwähnt, in den 90ern gab es DigiCash, einen anderen Versuch, digitales Geld zu schaffen. Und da war es andersrum. Da gab es also eine zentrale Instanz. Dafür war das Geld wirklich anonym. Und wie du schon ganz richtig erkannt hast, die Tatsache, dass jeder alle Transaktionen sieht, macht natürlich auch das Nachvollziehen von Transaktionen leichter. Es ist also nicht anonym, es ist aber immerhin pseudonym. Das heißt, es steht nicht an jedem Konto ein Name dran. Man muss nicht im Postident-Verfahren eine neue Bitcoin-Identität aufmachen, sondern man kann einfach in seinem Client auf den Knopf drücken und haben neuestes Konto.
Obwohl unsere Politiker das wahrscheinlich gerne hätten.
Ja, das haben sie schon gefordert. Also der Gesetzesvorschlag ist in der Pipeline, kommt noch. Und pseudonym heißt erstmal, der Name steht nicht dran. Aber natürlich kann man, wenn man sieht, von wo nach wo Geld überwiesen wurde, Geldflüsse nachvollziehen. Also wenn du jetzt auf deine Webseite deine Bitcoin-Adresse schreibst und guckst, da Spenden entgegennimmst, dann kann man nachgucken, blogexplorer.com heißt die Seite, wie viel Geld da angekommen ist, von welchen Adressen das gekommen ist und an welche Adressen das Geld gegangen ist. Und da ist es natürlich auch möglich, durch Anwendungen fortschrittlicher Technologie, größere Geldströme auch über mehrere Konten hinweg zu verfolgen.
Und jetzt ist es aber so, ich kann mir beliebig viele Konten einrichten. Also sagen, ein Bitcoin-Konto ist im Prinzip nur für mich als User eine lange Ziffernfolge und davon kann ich mir in diesem kleinen Programm beliebig viele klicken. Gibt es da nicht eine Möglichkeit, dass ich die Bitcoins so hin und her schiebe, bis irgendjemand so verwirrt ist?
Ja, lustigerweise ist es ja alles genau dasselbe, was schon immer passiert. Also wenn wir wieder dabei sind, ja wir kaufen 100 Tonnen Kokain aus Kolumbien und bezahlen die, dann muss das Geld da ja irgendwie hin und von da muss es wieder irgendwie weg und irgendjemand muss sich am Ende des Tages die Burger davon kaufen. Und auch da funktioniert tatsächlich die Verfolgung so gut, da stehen Namen dran an den Konten, aber das sind dann Schattenfirmen und Tarnidentitäten, die gar nicht wirklich existieren, also auch mehr der Wiener Pseudonym und sowohl die Technik zur Verschleierung als auch die Technik zur Aufdeckung ist eigentlich total identisch zu dem, was bei Bitcoin passieren, ich sag jetzt einfach mal passieren wird, ich weiß nicht, ob es schon passiert, aber es ist total absehbar, dass es passieren wird. Das heißt, auf Seiten der Leute, die illegale Geldströme verfolgen, sind das Analysetechniken, wo man sagen kann, naja, ich guck mal hier und dann habe ich hier eine Verbindung, also hier habe ich einen Namen und da habe ich einen Namen, jetzt guck doch mal nach, wie viel Geld da lang geflossen ist. Also die Informatiker haben sich vielleicht schon mal mit Flüssen in Grafen beschäftigt, in gerichteten Grafen, das sind genau diese Algorithmen. Und die Gegenseite, die Geldwäscher, tut natürlich genau das. Wir machen ganz viele Konten auf und schieben das von A nach B und wieder von B nach A und alles durcheinander und hoffen, dass das irgendwie keiner sieht.
Jetzt hast du, als wir schonmal darüber gesprochen haben, meintest du, man könnte sowas wie ein Remixer machen, gibt es ja dieses Tor-Netzwerk, wo man Verbindungen genauso lang durcheinander lässt. Geht das irgendwie?
Naja, im Prinzip ist das so eine Geldwaschmaschine, dass man entweder ganz viele Adressen hat und das Geld von vielen Leuten zwischen den vielen Adressen hin und her schiebt und dann hinten wieder rausschiebt, das geht zum Beispiel. Oder dass man eine Adresse hat, wo alle drauf einzahlen und alle wieder Geld rauskriegen und dann muss man halt darauf achten, dass es nicht auffällt. Also wenn ich es rein hypothetisch angenommen, ich würde so einen Dienst betreiben und du würdest jetzt kommen mit deinen 73 Bitcoin 26 und ich nehme das entgegen, schiebe das ein bisschen durch die Gegend und tu dann auf der anderen Seite wieder 73 Bitcoin 26 raus, dann ist es ganz egal, was in der Mitte passiert, du wirst schon aufgrund der Zahl gefunden. Wenn man sagt, man macht das ein bisschen sinnvoller, man zerlegt also die 73 Bitcoin 26 in lauter Einheiten zu 10 Bitcoin und das macht man mit allen, da kann man nur noch gucken, wie viel Geld pro Sekunde rausgefallen ist. Das heißt, man muss dann auch die Geldflussrate mitteln und komplexen statistischen Modellen. Also das ist so ein Statistiker-Wettstreit. Wer hat die besten Statistiker?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dass man immer wieder dieses klassische Wettrüsten hat. Leute fangen an, das zu verbergen, andere Leute fangen an, das nachzuverfolgen.
Naja, der zusätzliche Faktor, der auch noch reinkommt, ist, dass wenn du aus dem Bitcoinsystem austrittst, vielleicht dann dort unter Beobachtung stehst. Also wenn Andreas unter Beobachtung steht, weil man weiß, naja, der hat irgendwie was zu tun mit Dingen, die nicht sein sollen. Und dann schaut man sich die realen Geldflüsse, also quasi die Euro-Geldflüsse an, die Euro-Geldflüsse an, die zum Andreas gehen. Und das hat er vielleicht auch noch über Leute. Und dann kommt man auf die Bitcoin-Konten am Schluss.
Du meinst an den Stellen sozusagen, wo man Bitcoin in reales Geld umtauschen kann?
Also in dem Moment, wo es halt aus dem Bitcoin-Universum austritt, sind wieder die bekannten Verschleierungstechniken nur möglich.
Okay, da können wir gleich nochmal genauer drüber reden, wie man jetzt sagen, von dem Bitcoin zu richtigem Geld kommt. Weil über den Kurs, wir haben jetzt ganz schön die ganze Zeit schon geredet. Es war auch schon angesagt, dass es Umtauschbörsen gibt. Es gab in der letzten Zeit auch irgendwie zwei große Überfälle, kann man vielleicht sagen. Aber all das werden wir gleich nochmal genau klären und auch einen kleinen Zukunftsausblick wagen. Mit Markus Richter im Chaos Radio, der heute zu Besuch hat. Natürlich vom Chaos Computer Club in Gestalt von Andreas Bogk. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Und außerdem ist der Volkswirt Niels Kobschätzki da. Ja hallo, hallo, weil wir heute über Bitcoin sprechen. Eine virtuelle Währung. Was das heißt, haben wir schon geklärt. Wie das funktioniert auch. Wie man sich das Geld selber basteln kann, haben wir auch schon geklärt. Wie gesagt, man kann tatsächlich jetzt nur noch ganz kurz erklären. Das ist halt Währung, die vor allem im Netz stattfindet, die man sich selber zu Hause errechnen kann, wenn man sich einen Computer kauft, der richtig viele Grafikkarten hat und die ja vorbei an allen Geldinstituten funktioniert. Und ich wollte es nochmal genau fragen, wenn man diese Bitcoins hat, gibt es ja diese sogenannten Umtauschstellen. Wie genau funktioniert das da? Da gibt es Leute, die setzen sich mit einem Bauchladen auf die Straße und sagen, hier komm her mit deinen Bitcoins, ich geb dir richtiges Geld dafür.
Ja, ungefähr so funktioniert das ja.
Okay, und wie wird der Kurs festgelegt? Also woher wissen die, wie viel die mir dafür geben können?
Es ist der berühmte freie Markt. Also das funktioniert ein bisschen wie die Wiesenhandelsplätze auch funktionieren. Also so Börsen nennt man das üblicherweise. Das heißt, jemand kommt und sagt, ich hab hier Bitcoin und die würde ich gerne verkaufen und ich hätte gerne 15 Euro pro Stück. Dann kommt einer und sagt, ich will Bitcoin kaufen, aber ich biete dir nur 10 dafür. Dann gibt es ein sogenanntes Order Book. Das heißt, da wird eingetragen, wer wieviel bietet und wer wieviel bereit ist zu zahlen. Und wenn sich halt jemand findet, also ein Pärchen findet, das zusammenpasst, einen verkauft, dann wird diese Transaktion durchgeführt. Das heißt, diese Exchange-Webseiten tauschen gar nicht selber, sondern die vermitteln eigentlich bloß einen Tausch.
Okay, jetzt habt ihr ja vorhin schon ab und zu mal erklärt, wenn ein Early Adopter seine ganzen Bitcoins auf den Markt kippt, dann ist alles nichts mehr wert. Wie funktioniert das?
Na, muss ich überlegen. Man hat da die lange Liste von Leuten, die bereit sind, für Bitcoin Geld auszugeben. Der erste sagt, ich bin bereit, 14 Euro auszugeben. Der zweite sagt, ich bin bereit, 13 Euro auszugeben. Der dritte sagt, ich 10. Der nächste 5. Irgendjemand sagt, wenn sie 2 Cent kosten, dann kaufe ich auch noch welche. Und wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sozusagen dem ersten für 15 welche verkauft, dem nächsten für 12, dem dritten für 10 und dem letzten dann für 2 Cent, dann ist sozusagen der Kurs, was ja mehr oder weniger der Betrag der letzten Transaktionen ist, die passiert ist, nur noch 2 Cent.
Also der bedient quasi einfach alle Angebote und damit ist sozusagen der Markt leer und keiner will mehr Leute, will mehr Bitcoins kaufen und dann sind nur noch die ganzen niedrigen Angebote am Start. Genau. Und dann kommen die Spekulanten, die nutzen genau diesen Moment, um ganz viele Bitcoins zu kaufen und zu warten, bis es wieder viel mehr wert ist und dann...
Genau, also die Theorie ist, dass es gar nicht passieren kann, weil keiner so viel Bitcoin auf einmal hat, als dass es passieren könnte. Behaupten zumindest die Leute, dass es viele Leute gibt, die ein Interesse dran haben, die bloß auf eine Gelegenheit warten, billig an Bitcoins ranzukommen.
Das ist doch jetzt neulich auch gerade passiert, oder nicht?
Ja, allerdings durch einen Hack. Da wurde, Mount Gox ist eine von den größeren Exchange-Webseiten. Und die hatten da so ne kleine Sicherheitsschwankung und haben im Rahmen dieser Sicherheitsschwankung die Passwörter für ihre Accounts verloren. Und irgendjemand ist also rumgelaufen von Account zu Account und hat alle Bitcoins auf den Markt geworfen, die es gab.
Also wirklich alle die es gab oder alle die es gab? Also haben die wirklich alle Accounts aufgemacht, oder?
Das ist ein bisschen unklar. Ob es alle waren, ob es ein Teil der Accounts war, ich glaube es sah so ein bisschen aus, als wären alle. Weil es sind glaube ich 500.000 Bitcoins an dem Tag verkauft worden. Und das klingt schon, das ist wohl mehr als einer auf einmal besitzt. Wenn man den diversen Statistiken glauben kann, die Leute in den Foren so anstellen über die Verteilung des Besitzes an Bitcoins.
Und daraufhin ist sozusagen der ganze Markt zusammengebrochen?
Daraufhin ist der Markt zusammengebrochen, ja, weil der Kurs dann auf ein oder zwei Cent runtergegangen ist, weil wie gesagt alle Kaufgebote wurden erfüllt, alle Orders wurden erfüllt. Und dann wurde natürlich erstmal dieser Exchange geschlossen für eine Weile. Die Transaktionen wurden rückabgewickelt. Das ist vielleicht ein ganz spannender Punkt, weil eigentlich kann man eine Bitcoin Zahlung nicht rückabwickeln. Das ist nicht so wie bei einer Überweisung, wo man seine Bank anrufen kann, sagen kann, hey, da ist was schiefgelaufen. Und Lastschrift ist ein besseres Beispiel, weil da kommt es tatsächlich öfter vor, man sagt, hier bitte zurück buchen. Das geht nicht. Allerdings ist es so, dass diese Käufe und Verkäufe erst mal nur auf dieser Webseite passiert sind. Das heißt, man lädt Bitcoins auf die Webseite hoch oder man überweist Geld dahin. Dann hat man ein Guthaben auf der Webseite in Bitcoin oder Dollar. Dann kann man anfangen zu handeln. Dann kann man irgendwann anfangen, sich den Kram wieder auszahlen zu lassen. Und das ist halt noch nicht passiert. Also es ist ein bisschen passiert. Teilweise ist der Geld abgeflossen. So Leute sind reich geworden, die es nicht verdient haben, aber nicht besonders hohen Größenordnungen. Und viele dieser, in Anführungszeichen, unerwünschten Transaktionen, durch wie auch immer diese Passwörter gefunden hat, die wurden ruhig abgewickelt.
Das heißt also solange, aber genau, der andere Punkt ist also zu sagen, sobald so eine Transaktion im Bitcoinsystem selbst passiert ist, lässt sie sich ja nicht mehr rückgängig machen.
Genau. Das ist wirklich wie Bargeld.
Und da gab es auch auch einen Fall.
Ja, da gab es zumindest einen Fall, der bekannt geworden ist. Jemand hatte 26.000 Bitcoins gemeint, also auch jemand, der lange dabei war.
Holy shit!
Ja, schon bei dem derzeitigen Kurs der Gegenwert eines Eigenheims. Und da ist jemand in den Rechner eingebrochen, über ganz normal Trojaner, und hat die Wallet.dat geklaut. Also die Datei in Bitcoin kleint, wo der Schlüssel drinsteckt, mit dem man die Transaktionen unterschreiben kann. Und als er am nächsten Morgen aufwachte, war sein Konto leergeräumt, da war das Geld weg.
Das zu sagen, das ist letztendlich auch nicht mehr rückgängig. Das ist zu sagen, wie jemand, der in ein Haus einbricht und sozusagen 26.000 Euro in Bargeld klaut, das ist dann einfach dort. Wenn man den Typen selber nicht findet, ist es fort.
Genau, also man kann natürlich sehen, im ewigen Logfile, auf welches Konto das überwiesen wurde. Und wenn derjenige sich dumm anstellt, dann taucht irgendwann mal sein Name auf dem Zusammenhang mit diesem Geld. Aber wenn er halbwegs schlau ist, wird das nicht passieren.
Das heißt also, so anonym ist es dann doch schon. Man kann zwar die Transaktionen nachverfolgen, aber es ist trotzdem nicht so einfach, Netznetzen einzelnen Typen zu finden.
Das ist nicht unbedingt einfach, nein.
Wie heißt das dann, würde ich dir empfehlen, wenn man Bitcoins hat, dann soll man das eigentlich auf einem dedizierten eigenen Rechner machen? Weil eigentlich hat ja jeder Rechner Sicherheitslücken.
Ja, das hängt immer so ein bisschen von den Mengen ab, die man durch die Gegend bewegt. Wenn man da so eine 1, 2 Bitcoins hat, das ist als hätte man 10 oder 20 Euro in die Tasche. Wenn man die verliert, gut, ist ärgerlich, aber es ist kein Beinbruch. Aber wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20.000 Bitcoins, also sowas wie 300.000 Euro, ein bisschen weniger, 250 sind es schon. Wenn man das rumzulegen hat, und das einfach auf einem ganz normalen PC, mit dem man sich dann abends seine Pornos anguckt, das ist...
Das macht doch niemand.
Das ist schon ein purer Leichensinn.
Ja, da hat es dann jemand erwischt. Jetzt haben wir noch 20 Minuten, dann ist die Sendung schon vorbei. Ich würde gerne mal jetzt die Frage stellen, ob man sich dargestellt hat, dass ja bei Bitcoin diese Hoffnung verbunden ist, dass es etwas ganz Neues ist. Den Eindruck, den ich habe, ist aber eigentlich, dass das eine nette Spielerei ist. Mit der man auch reich werden kann, aber das kann man ja mit Börsenspielen auch. Aber eigentlich ist das nur so eine Art Test. Wie seht ihr das? Hat Bitcoin eine Zukunft im Sinne von, dass wir genau dieses System in 15, 20, 30 Jahren immer noch haben werden oder ist das jetzt sozusagen der erste Schritt in der Richtung sozusagen virtuelle Währung und da kommt möglicherweise dann aber nochmal was anderes, Neues, Besseres? Oder ist Bitcoin quasi das Facebook des virtuellen Geldes?
Ähm, ist Facebook nicht auch gerade am Eingehen? Aber naja, mein Eindruck ist der, dass also ich hab Bitcoin von einem Jahr ungefähr schon wahrgenommen und ich hab mir gedacht, das wird nie erfolgreich. Das wird nie was. Das ist viel zu abgedreht. Das verstehen die Leute nicht. Und bin eigentlich auch überrascht, wie erfolgreich es schon geworden ist. Mein Bauchgefühl ist, also irgendwas stimmt da noch nicht. Irgendwie wird es gegen die Wand laufen. Das ist ein glorioses Experiment. Und mindestens werden wir viel davon lernen. Also ich würde nicht meine Hand dafür ins Feuer legen, dass Bitcoin in einem Jahr noch existiert oder zwei. Aber nachdem meine letzte Vorhersage über, wie Bitcoin sich entwickeln wird, falsch war, kann ich auch nicht ausschließen, es ist total erfolgreich sein wird. Und 20 Jahre weiter begleiten wird.
Ich denke auch nicht, dass man es ausschließen kann. Ich denke aber eher, dass Bitcoin, also dass genau das Bitcoin eher erstmal Nischensystem bleiben wird. Also das ist begrenzt. Leute, diese begrenzte Anzahl kann natürlich sechsstellig sein, siebenstellig. Es gibt eine Menge Internetnutzer, also weltweit. Aber dass es trotzdem bei einem Nischensystem bleibt, weil einem Großteil der Leute einfach mal Dezentralität und diese Pseudonymität relativ egal ist und die Leute lieber ihre Waren in echter Währung shoppen. Also nicht in echter, sondern in ihrer eigenen Landeswährung. Also Sie, Amazon, die gerade Großwerbung damit machen, dass man jetzt ihren Kindle in Euro, ihre Bücher in Euro kaufen kann, statt in Dollar wie vorher. Also die Leute wollen einfach in ihrer eigenen Mehrung einkaufen. Es ist natürlich auch eine Frage, wie sich die Transaktionskosten entwickeln. Es gibt Firmen, die gezeigt haben, dass man sehr kleine Transaktionspreise, sagen wir mal 79 Cent, einen Euro, schon mit einer Kreditkarte abwickeln kann. Wenn das weiter runtergeht, ist auch an dem Punkt Bitcoin nicht unbedingt stärker aufgestellt. Es ist aber halt für diese Nische, die jetzt an, also die an das Experiment glaubt oder die halt dem System TM nicht vertraut. Für die ist das natürlich eine feine Sache. Von der kryptographischen Seite habe ich jetzt nicht so die Ahnung, um jetzt sagen zu können, das müsste besser laufen oder man müsste dieses komplette System anders aufbauen oder dass man da noch was anderes findet. Aber es ist sicherlich ein schickes Experiment, um mal anzuschauen, was dann da so passiert.
Jetzt gab es vor zwei Tagen die Meldung, dass es ein neues Geldwäschegesetz gibt, glaube ich. Ich glaube 1000 Euro ist dann die Grenze, alles, was da drüber ist, das muss dann gemeldet werden. Glaubt ihr, es gibt überhaupt eine Chance für anonymes Bezahlen im Internet? Anonymes Bezahlen von Kleinstbeträgen im Netz?
Ich denke, das ist ein bisschen so wie mit der Versuch, Alkohol zu verbieten. Das hat ja auch nur sehr eingeschränkt funktioniert, oder überhaupt Drogen zu verbieten, also Anonymität im Internet zu verbieten. Dazu gehört ja Bezahlen im Internet, das ist ja ein Teilaspekt von Anonymität im Internet. Es existiert ein extrem großer Bedarf dafür. Man kann versuchen, das zu illegalisieren, das wird es aber nicht unterbinden.
Okay, aber was man jetzt vermuten könnte ist, dass sich da, was Niels gerade sagte, irgendwie da so Kleinstbeträge mit Kreditkarten, da gibt es schon Anbieter, die können das, dass sich das einfach weiter durchsetzen können, also durchsetzen wird im Sinne von, es ist für die größeren Teil der Leute bequemer.
Ja, vielleicht ist es ein Grund. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie mit den Transaktionskosten so weit runterkommen werden, weil man bei Kreditkarten immer das Betrugsproblem hat. Das sind echt enorme Volumen, die sie da in Fraud investieren. Es gibt ein paar technische Gründe, die dagegen sprechen, dass das Bitcoin-System so wie es gerade existiert, sich weiter verbreiten wird. Teilweise gibt es Lösungsansätze, teilweise nicht. Das Problem ist, dass man ja dieses ewige Lockfile hat und dass man alle Transaktionen sieht. Das heißt, man hat auch eine Datei auf der Platte, wo alle Transaktionen ever drin sind. Und die wird natürlich immer größer. Es gibt erste Ansätze, das Problem zu lösen, dem man sagt, man hebt sich halt nicht die gesamte ewige Liste auf, sondern man glaubt den Kontostand von letzter Woche, merkt sich den und schreibt bloß inkrementell die Änderungen weg und regelmäßig schmeißt man halt den alten Kram raus. Das andere Problem ist, dass ja alle Transaktionen in diesem Peer-to-Peer-System ge-broadcasted werden. Das heißt, jeder schickt alle Transaktionen, die passieren an alle. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, wie viele Millionen Leute, wie viele zigtausende Transaktionen pro Sekunde über alte Zahlungssysteme abwickeln, heißt es auch, dass es ein enormer Traffic ist. Also man braucht eine enorme Bandbreite, wenn man sich mal vorstellt, dass 5 oder 10 Millionen Leute oder 100 Millionen Leute Bitcoin benutzen. Und dafür gibt es halt noch keine wirkliche Lösung. Und das sind so die technischen Herausforderungen, wo Bitcoin am Erfolg nochmal scheitern könnte.
Was denn jetzt hat Sophia gerade noch angerufen und die meint, hallo und guten Abend?
Ja, ich hab mir so ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht, wie das vielleicht auch so in der Zukunft des Bitcoins aussehen könnte. Und ja, also wie ich mir das vorstelle, wäre halt einfach, dass Bitcoin auch einfach erstmal ein Türöffner ist für alle möglichen anderen Sachen, die man sich halt vorstellen könnte. Also es gibt da halt ja auch so Systeme wie Ripple, was ja im Prinzip, wo halt im Prinzip insgesamt kein Geld drunter ist, sondern sich nur gegensätzlich die Leute Kredit geben. Aber das sind halt Freunde voneinander. Oder... Was ist das?
Hat das einer von euch auf dem Schirm hier? Nee, was ist das?
auch halbwegs dezentrales System, wo man sich und sein soziales Umfeld reinmachen kann und denen sagen kann, ja, denen würde ich so und so viel Kredit geben. Dann kann man das machen. Und das Interessante ist, dass dadurch die Kredite auch von dem einen zum anderen wandern können. Also, dass man...
Also eine Kreditweitergabe über verschiedene Funktionen. Und du meinst also, dass Bitcoin dazu führen kann, dass einfach andere alternative Bezahlsysteme jetzt an den Start kommen?
Genau.
Seht ihr das auch so, dass es ein Angebot gibt für viele weitere Neue? Gibt es überhaupt gerade schon Ideen, das weiter zu entwickeln? Oder ist es bis bei Bitcoins gerade erst mal Schluss?
Na, das Bitcoinsystem selber ist, ja wie gesagt, Skalierbarkeit ist da gerade das große Zauberwort. Es gibt andere Ansätze für digitales Geld. Es gibt eine Website, da gibt es bestimmt zwei Dutzend historische und gerade laufende Versuche, digitales Geld einzuführen, alternative Währungssysteme einzuführen. Es gibt ja auch schon immer Versuche, Alternativwährungen zu etablieren. Also auf Tauschbasis. Dann kommt man mit einem Tausch-Umrechnungssystem. Gab es nicht auch in Kreuzberg mal so eine Alternativwährung zum Beispiel?
Ich weiß nicht, in Dresden werden jedes Jahr immer zu der Bundesrepublik Neustadt, glaube ich, immer eigenes Geld ausgegeben.
Im Irak gab es eine Alternativwährung, die jahrelang zur offiziellen Währung im Herlief, vor allen Dingen im kurdischen Bereich.
Okay, Niels, ich habe noch mal die Frage. Du hast ja den Unterschied gemacht zwischen realer und virtueller Währung, und dabei dein Kriterium Institutionen. Das heißt ja momentan noch Staaten. Siehst du, dass das auch in Zukunft das Maß der Dinge sein wird? Weil das eine der interessanten Dinge an Bitcoin ist, dass es einfach eine Nicht-Staatenwährung ist. Es gibt ja in Science-Fiction-Szenarien häufiger, dass Leute, dass dann Firmengeld, dass so ein Firmengeld sprang, also dass eine Firma eine Währung ausgibt. Glaubst du, dass es in Zukunft immer noch Staatengeld geben wird? Oder wird es möglicherweise andere Währungsausgeber geben können? Also Facebook-Credit zum Beispiel wäre so ein Beispiel.
Das hat sehr weit gegriffen.
Wir spekulieren zum Schluss nochmal.
Die Sache ist ja die, dass ich ja immer noch etwas hab, was sich öffentliche Güter nennt. Also sowas wie Parks, Umwelt oder ähnliches. Und das ist ja was zum Beispiel über Steuern mitfinanziert wird. Also dass meine Straße nach Möglichkeit keine Schlaglöcher hat. Da kommt der Staat nicht unbedingt hinterher. Oder dass nicht jeder mit einer Benzinschleuder die Luft zu pestet. Von daher bräuchte man diese öffentlichen Güter, die ja jeder konsumiert und die nur so pseudomäßig eingesch... also uneingeschränkt verfügbar sind, aber trotzdem jeder konsumiert, die das kontrollieren bzw. das bezahlen. Und wäre halt die Frage, ob sich da andere Institutionen bilden, die das halt realisieren können. Sagen wir mal Großkonzerne, wenn wir irgendwie den Umstieg haben, dass Großkonzerne auf einmal extra territoriale Gebiete erschließen können, also wo sie unabhängig sind von den Staaten und dort dafür aufkommen, dass es bei ihnen die Wiesen schön grün sind und alles und Leute dort leben wollen, dann könnte es natürlich staatenlose Währungen geben. Es ist die Frage allerdings, ob eine entsprechende Entwicklung stattfinden wird.
Aber Währung ist für dich immer auch mit einem Gebiet verknüpft, was es geben muss, muss ich sagen. Ich empfinde ja zum Beispiel, es gibt ja zum Beispiel, was man auch als Währung benutzen könnte, es gibt ja diese Online-Shops zum Beispiel, oder ich überlege gerade, bei PC-Spielen wird tatsächlich immer noch mit realem Geld immer bezahlt.
Da kann man mit Bitcoin einsetzen.
Nee, aber du hast ja quasi schon zu sagen, es gibt ja diese Points, das sind ja Punkte quasi. Das ist ja schon eine Art virtuelle Währung, weil man sich das weiter denkt. Also wenn jetzt irgendwie ein Supermarkt angefangen würde, irgendwie iTunes oder Playstation oder Xbox Punkte zu akzeptieren, ist sowas.
Ja, das passiert ja teilweise. Also diese berühmten Meilen, wenn man Vielflieger ist, mit denen kann man ja auch schon Dinge kaufen. Und dann, wenn man ein Hotel einsteigt, kriegt man dann auch Meilen, wo man sich gar nicht bewegt dabei. Also vieles davon existiert ja partiell schon in manchen Märkten. Und sicherlich wird das weitergehen. In einer Welt, in der Nationalstaaten an Bedeutung verlieren gegenüber Konzernen, das ist natürlich auch naheliegend, dass dann auch die Konzerne anfangen, Währung rauszugeben. Und genau das ist natürlich der Punkt, wo man mit einem Gegeneinsatz, der halt nicht zentralisiert auf eine große Organisation ist, möglicherweise auch den Lauf der Weltgeschichte anders steuern kann. Also weiß nicht, ob wir mit Franchise-Staaten so glücklich werden.
Ich empfehle Snowcrush zu lesen, von Niels Stevenson. Hieß er, ein Nationalist-Buch, wo so ein Gesellschaftssystem auch beschrieben wird. Ich möchte jetzt ganz zum Schluss nochmal kurz die Frage stellen, nach der Geschichte dahinter. Also du hast ja gerade erzählt, irgendwie der Nachbar von einem der Programmierer verkauft Socken. Das sind Bitcoins. Weiß man jetzt genau, wer das gemacht hat? Also ich habe mal versucht nachzulesen. Es gibt irgendwie so, es gibt einen ominösen Typen mit einem japanisch klingenden Namen, der irgendwie so mal ein Paper geschrieben haben soll, was darauf basiert. Also kann man irgendwo diese Geschichte nachlesen? Gibt es da was?
Ja, man kann sich auf bitcoin.org das Paper runterladen. Also tatsächlich hat er das Paper geschrieben, während er die Software geschrieben hat, also sozusagen eigentlich seine Software dokumentiert. Und nein, man weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Wer legt denn dann diese Schwierigkeiten fest? Das wird ja anscheinend angepasst über Zeitintervalle?
Ja, das ist in der Software festgeschrieben. Also es ist mehr oder weniger schon eine Konvention, die alle Leute, die jetzt drin dran beteiligt sind, einhalten. Das heißt alle verwenden dieselbe Software. Bestimmte Regeln sind in diese Software einprogrammiert. Also so ganz komplett dezentral ist es nicht. Also es gibt schon noch Möglichkeiten das System zu beeinflussen über die Software, die das tut, weil die genau solche Regeln festlegt. Wie zum Beispiel, wie viel Bitcoins rausgegeben werden.
Wer gibt dir dann raus diese Software? Also wo kommt die denn her? Die muss ja irgendwo...
Da gibt es ein Entwicklerteam und die kann man runterladen. Also sozusagen in Anführungszeichen ganz normale Internet-Open-Source-Software.
Und wer das Entwicklerteam ist, weiß man aber auch nicht so genau.
Doch, die sind relativ bekannt. Einer von denen hat auch schon eine Einladung zur CIA bekommen. Er soll doch mal vortragen, was das ist und wie das funktioniert. Der Termin müsste bald sein.
Und da geht er auch hin, weiß man das?
Da geht er hin, ja.
Das ist ja schon auf dem Weg außer Landes. Verstehe, verstehe. Gut. Haben wir da noch was vergessen? Oder sind wir dann durch mit den Bitcoins?
Ich glaube, wir sind so gut wie fast durch. Namecoin hat noch jemand im Chat erwähnt. Namecoin ist quasi der Versuch, die Bitcoin Software dazu zu verwenden, ein dezentrales Namensauflösungssystem fürs Internet zu bauen. Also DNS, was schon, wenn du www.fritz.de eingibst in dein Browser, läuft der Browser ja zur deutschen Registry für DE und fragt, wer denn Fritz ist. Und dann kriegt er einen Verweis auf den Names, aber der sagt fritz.de ist da hinten. Dann läuft man da und sagt, wer ist denn für die Webseite zuständig, kriegt eine Adresse raus. Und dieses Namensauflösungssystem ist halt auch ein zentrales System. Es ist ein Route-Name-Server. Und Namecoin ist jetzt also der Versuch, die Dezentralität von Bitcoins, das technische System zu nutzen, um ein verteiltes Namensystem zu bauen. Wobei der Erste, der einen Namen will, sagt, ich will jetzt den Namen, dann wird das in die ewige Liste eingetragen. Und dann kann den auch nie wieder jemand wegnehmen. Ohne zentrale Instanz.
Oh, okay. Und ist das schon ein Erfolgversprechen? Das ist dann aber ein Parallelsystem, das existiert.
Genau, das ist mit der Software für die Bitcoins sehr eng verwandt. Es funktioniert sehr, sehr ähnlich, aber es hat seine eigene Blockchain, also seine eigene Kette.
Aber ich muss sagen, es ist aber auch ein Parallelsystem zum herkömmlichen DNS-System, das jetzt noch existiert.
Genau, weil dezentral und nicht zentral.
Stimmt, in der Tat. Verrücktes Backofenzeug, also wenn ihr euch die guten, guten, guten Domains sichern wollt. Dann solltet ihr jetzt gleich auf Namecoins umsteigen. Gut, dann haben wir für die Bitcoins den Podcast zu dieser Sendung. Gibt es, wie gesagt, in einer Stunde auf fritz.de. Im Verlauf des nächsten Tages dann auch auf chaosradio.de. Fragen dazu könnt ihr gerne noch stellen im Blog zum Chaosradio unter chaosradio.de. Wer hätte das gedacht? Außerdem will doch bestimmt noch mal die Gelegenheit ergriffen werden, um Werbung zu machen für dieses kleine Ding, was da stattfindet im Sommer. Da bist du doch auch irgendwie mit verbandet, oder?
Ja, genau. Da gibt es nämlich das Chaos Communication Camp vom 10. bis 14. August in Finofort. Und wir werden fünf Tage zelten und hacken und Club-Mate trinken und schnelles Internet haben und in der Sonne liegen und es in den Bauch pinseln.
Und da darf jeder hinkommen?
Ja.
Da kann man sich dann irgendwie ein Ticket bei euch holen?
Genau, Ticket gibt es auf der Webseite. Einfach mal bei Events.cde gucken.
Dein persönliches Programmhighlight, hast du schon eins?
Äh, nee, noch nicht.
Okay, dann ist jetzt der bei uns raus. Kann man euch jetzt nicht vorhersagen. Gut, dann vielen Dank. Andreas Bogk vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio. Vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein. Niels Kobschätzki, der Volkswirt. Vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein. Ich verabschiede mich an dieser Stelle. Das Chaos Radio ist also vorbei. Hiernach kommt mit Henrik Schröder der Nightflight, wo es Punk-Musik geben wird, wie ich den guten Mann kenne. Ich wünsche euch dabei viel Spaß. Mir bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen. Macht immer schon eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.